[Musique]
il y a plusieurs chemins pour réussir sa
vie et l'engagement est un de ces
chemins l'engagement donne du sens
l'engagement montre le sens comme une
boussole
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous donner
envie de vous engager
l' envie d'avoir envie je suis un
industriel
je suis entrepreneur être entrepreneur
c'est faire des choix avec une dose
d'inconscience face à la prise de risque
et une dose de courage face à l'inconnu
quand vous prenez une décision
vous avez trois possibilités comme un
animal face au danger vous réfugiez
subir fuir ou alors s'engager c'est à
dire agir et entreprendre c'est agir
pour créer du sens c'est ce qui m'anime
mais entreprendre c'est aussi avoir peur
que tu dis tant que nous ne nous
engageons pas le doute règne
nous partageons tous les mêmes peur la
peur du risque
la peur de l'échec la peur de la
solitude la peur jugement du regard des
autres et ces peurs sont pour la plupart
non fondées elles sont créés par notre
tête
zen nous freine et s'engager c'est
dépasser nos peurs j'ai toujours eu peur
à chaque fois que je me suis engagé
s'engager c'est perdre des repères pour
en créer de nouveaux j'ai eu peur
pendant mes études j'ai eu peur pendant
mon mariage j'ai eu peur d'avoir des
enfants
j'ai eu peur de créer mes entreprises et
aujourd'hui devant vous
j'ai peur mais la peur est un formidable
levier l'engagement et je vous propose
de vivre ensemble et pour cela je vous
invite à fermer les yeux
vous êtes un skieur mais par n'importe
quel skieurs vous êtes dans un portillon
de départ
mais pas n'importe quel portillon vous
allez descendre la strife la piste de
descente de kitzbühel en autriche sous
vos skis un mur 84 degré de pente
vous allez sauter dans le vide et vous
tenez vos bâtons vous vous préparez à
pousser
ressentez vous la pression l'enjeu la
peur imaginez les pulsations de votre
coeur imaginez votre tête qui fait et
refait le tracé 6 5 4 3 ah désolé mais
votre départ est reporté
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux pourquoi
devant tant d'émotion tant de peur on
s'engage on décide d'y aller parce que
ça fait sens et personnellement je l' ai
vécu m'engager pour le sens tout en
disant mais qu'est ce que je fous là en
2013 j'ai été élu président du cjd
france une association de 5000
entrepreneurs depuis dim qui milite
depuis 1938 pour mettre l'économie au
service de l'homme
je décide de passer quatre jours par
semaine pour cette association pendant
trois ans je le veux j'en suis fier je
veux défendre les fondamentaux du
mouvement c'est-à-dire former les
dirigeants son métier d'entreprise et
influencé pour imaginer la société de
demain
je suis
fier de m'engager pour ce mouvement qui
m'a fait grandir donné après avoir reçu
je me dis quand même
qu'est ce que je fous là qu'est ce que
je fous là j'ai peur de perdre le lien à
ma femme à mes enfants de perdre mes
entreprises
j'ai peur des balades et de ville en
ville j'ai peur de ne pas être capable
j'ai peur pas y arriver et ce sont les
autres qui m'aide
ce sont les personnes importantes dans
ma vie ma femme mes enfants mes
collaborateurs les autres adhérents
entrepreneurs qui me disent tu peux y
aller tu peux le faire
il me met dans le portillon et ils me
disent on croit en toi
on compte sur toi et de cette expérience
j'ai compris tu es un engagement porteur
de sens devait se prendre avec le coeur
et avec la tête et j'en ai tiré quatre
enseignements quatre points cardinaux
pour garder le cap pour continuer à
vivre une vie pleine de sens le premier
point l'envi vous y aller parce que vous
avez envie vous sentez qu'à l'intérieur
de vous ça bout à l'idée de vivre des
nouvelles expériences
vous êtes excité heureux enthousiastes
peu importe ce qui va arriver
vous avez envie d'y aller vous devez le
vivre ça vous construit ça vous fait
évoluer ça fait sens deuxième point
l'equilibre maintenir un déséquilibre
stable dans la vie vous avez trois
piliers le pro non pas dans cet ordre là
le perso
le pro et le social et le sociétal
imaginez un tabouret à trois pieds dont
un des pieds est beaucoup plus grand que
l'autre
vous ne tenez pas longtemps en équilibre
quand j'ai décidé de passer quatre jours
par semaine en dehors de ma famille et
de mon temps et de mes entreprises c'est
parce que ma femme mes enfants mes
collaborateurs m'ont dit ok c'est le bon
moment
si j'avais pris une telle responsabilité
dix ans avant je n'aurais pas pu avec
des jeunes enfants ou avec une
entreprise tout juste reprise ou alors
au détriment des autres piliers de ma
vie le troisième point
l'apprentissage s'engager c'est se
confronter à l'inconnu tout au long de
votre vie vous apprenez vous vous
engagez vous apprenez prenez la conduite
au départ vous avez peur vous vérifiez
tout vous êtes mal à l'aise
et puis à force de conduire vous prenez
confiance toute phase d'apprentissage
est difficile mais elle est nécessaire à
toute évolution
quand vous vous engagez vous apprenez à
comprendre comment vous fonctionnez pour
mieux accompagner les autres à accepter
vos peurs et vos envies
à découvrir d'autres modes de pensée et
à choisir une nouvelle posture de vie
qui fait sens et la posture qui m'a
inspiré pendant mon mandat du cjd et qui
me guident encore aujourd'hui quand je
dois prendre une décision faire
autrement
penser différemment pour imaginer de
nouveaux modèles
quatrième point le sens s'engager pour
vivre une aventure qui fait sens
ils se sont engagés pour une cause
nelson mandela
coluche mère teresa je me suis engagé
pour la cause du cjd
elle me parle mettre l'économie au
service de l'homme
la cause est fondamentale
mais elle n'est pas suffisante les
personnes qui vous accompagnent sont
essentiels ce qui compte c'est la vente
sûrs que vous allez vivre avec les
autres au service de la cause je vous
invite à méditer cette phrase de paulo
coelho
si vous pensez que l'aventuré dangereuse
essayez la routine elle est mortelle
l'engagement est un chemin pour réussir
sa vie et pour vous guider sur ce chemin
gardez en tête quatre points quatre
points cardinaux le sens l'equilibre
l'apprentissage et l'envi je vous invite
à nouveau à fermer les yeux et à les
garder fermées c'est votre départ c'est
vous qui choisissez votre piste
vous allez être dans votre portillon
écoutez vos envies ressentez vos
émotions décidé avec raison l'engagement
est une chance que vous avez de
découvrir véritablement qui vous êtes
indépendamment de ce qu'on vous a dit
que vous étiez
et n'est ce pas là finalement le vrai
sens de l'engagement donner aux autres
celle ou celui que je suis merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]